quand vous êtes plutôt un mec simple
sympa etc
on va vous faire une interview de stars
on ne touchera pendant ne bouge pas voir
le bush le moral revient le b fice
relève la tête
donc c'est l'interview alain delon donc
sa maman de ces dames lamentable c'est
évitable
c'est misérable alors oui le début de
chaque au début de chaque réponse oui
vous devez dire pierre arditi pense que
bien un oui d'accord bakassi je
comprends alors légaliser les drogues
douces vous trouvé l'idée stupéfiante où
vous trouvez stupéfiants qu'on n'est pas
encore fait
il ya un an dit il il pense que c'est
plutôt stupéfiants qu'on n'ait pas au
moins essayer de le faire voilà votre
conception du luxe c'est boire du coca
dans un verre en cristal ou du petrus
dans un gobelet en plastique
ah bah alors écoutez ça va non non non
non
bah pierre arditi pense que le luxe
suprême serait tout de même de boire du
petrus et pas dans une coupe en cristal
mais dans un wagon dans lequel on peut
faire tourner ce vin pour en sortir tous
les arômes à ce que le petrus et 1,20 à
meerab voilà ce qu'il pense pierre hardy
pour taper la frime vous préféré rouler
sans bornes en ferrari avec un boudin ou
dix bornes en tracteur avec un canon il
préfère rouler 10 bornes en tracteur
avec un canon mais qui gére arditi
pour vous le plus choquant c'est
l'interdiction des mariages homos ou la
banalisation des divorces hétéro pour
pierre arditi c'est évidemment
l'interdiction des mariages homos qui
noyautent l'opus bien entendu bien voilà
pour faire du social
vous pensez qu'il faut augmenter les
salaires ou diminuer le temps de travail
via pierre arditi et très emmerder mais
il va arriver il va répondre
il va répondre je ne peux pas répondre
aussi crûment jeu même qu'hier arditi
dans même pierre arditi ne peut pas bien
leur dit et pense qu' il n'est pas
forcément obligatoire de réduire le
temps de travail
pire a dit qu'ils pensent qu'il serait
bon de d'augmenter certains salaires
parce que ça fait repartir l'économie
que ça permet aux gens de vivre moins
mal
il ya personne qui pense qu'il ya peut
être un moyen terme à trouver entre une
durée du temps de travail qui serait pas
codifié à coups de serpe bien la vie ne
peut pas codifié à coups de serpe et le
travail c'est aussi d'avis mais pierre
arditi pense qu'effectivement surtout
pour des gens qui gagnent peu leur vie
c'est qu'il voit assez souvent même au
cours de la sienne de vie de pierre
arditi pense quand même qu'il serait
mieux que les gens qui gagnent peu
d'argent à gagner un peu plus allemand
ferait pas de mal
voilà ce que pense pirates
les choses sont lancées ça tombe bien il
est chaud il adore dire son nom
jouissant oui bah oui bon c'est pour ça
qu'il est toujours à l'antenne alors on
va parler du commerce du sexe
êtes vous pour la réouverture des
maisons closes ou pour la fermeture des
boîtes à partouzes pierre arditi dira on
est dans la merde qui franchement la
pierre arditi les pour
o pour coup alors je suis pour la jeune
fille pour la réouverture des boîtes à
partout n'importe quoi pardon maintenant
dans mon estime hans wanner qu'il faut
s'excuser
inventeur il le fait tous les soirs
danger de 8 ha qui vient de le trouver
pour garder celle que vous aimez
est-ce que vous préféreriez l'enfermer
dans un palais où là sortiront des clubs
échangistes je serais capable de faire
le pire a dit qu'ils seraient capables
de faire les deux pour garder celle
qu'il aime parce qu'il a vraiment aucune
envie de la perdre et donc il pourrait
l'enfermer dans un palais si elle le
voulait bien où la trimballer dans un
club échangiste si c'était le seul moyen
de la gare démissionner d'accord pour le
club échangiste il le ferait s'il y
avait pas d'autre moyen des jeunes
seulement il est d'accord il chérit et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux